Welcome back Master and Mistress!
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello...
Hello, hello, hello... Welcome to...
Devil May Cry 4!
Oh my gosh, we already got through 3 games.
We just have 2 more.
2 more games!
Yippee!
I'm back!
Welcome back!
I say we have a birthday.
So early!
So early in the stream!
I will sing happy birthday real fast.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear organizer!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Yeah!
Yeah,
I don't know anything about Devil May Cry 4.
So, no spoilers!
Hold on, I think I'm gonna make myself a little bit smaller.
I'll move myself over a little bit too.
I don't know what the interface is like.
I don't know what the UI is like, so...
Welcome to Devil May Cry 4.
Minto, as always, good luck, have fun, try not to die.
There will be death.
But, apparently we've gotten over the biggest hurdle, no?
So, Devil May Cry 3 was like...
The biggie.
Dude, I welcome the membership.
Thank you!
Peace Walker for the road and Devil May Cry 4 at home.
Like high school and college video gaming all over again.
This one is your favorite for a long time?
I think, from what I've heard, most people like 5.
Is that true?
4 and 5 are the best.
5 is just a better version of 4.
5 is peak.
And 3.
3 and 5 are the favorites.
It's also my birthday.
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Yuzu Chino.
Happy birthday.
I should have been the one to fill your dark soul with wine.
The time has come and so have I.
Is that from this game or something?
Why does everyone keep saying that?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much for the 1500.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Should we just jump into it then?
Maybe.
I like how it's just legendary Dark Knight.
I'm assuming Nero Dante is the standard.
Right?
I assume.
It's my birthday on Friday.
Oh my gosh.
Happy birthday.
I can't keep singing birthday songs.
I'm going to dark the stream.
But I will sing one more.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday TV's brand.
Happy birthday!
Every time I scroll in chat that's why it does this.
Okay.
Did you watch the opening Vergil cutscene?
Oh no I didn't.
I didn't.
DMC3.
Do I need to watch that before this game?
Oh my gosh, John.
Thank you for another.
Another 50.
Thank you.
No, I don't have to.
It's not important.
Let's just get started then.
The first one?
This one?
But look how smug he looks here.
This one...
Feels more Dante though.
Maybe.
Almost a year.
Thank you Cooper!
Maybe.
But this one looks so smug.
This is the canon one.
Oh we can change later?
Oh okay.
Imagine if Minto gets slapped with an instant easy mode is now available in the first mission.
Stop!
I'm going to be bad at the game.
Imagine if the Vtuber is bad at the game.
The first time she's ever played it.
Imagine!
Stop it!
Why you no flawless?
I guess I'll go with this one.
Oh my gosh.
Wait what?
A mode recommended for those new to Devil May Cry series.
Well I mean technically I'm new but...
A mode for... Okay I'm guessing it's easy, normal, difficult.
A mode for those who have faced the demonic hordes of Devil May Cry and lived to tell the tale.
I'm dead.
I haven't lived anything.
The overwhelming number of demons lurking in this mode demand the very best of one's abilities.
Even the descriptions are turning in.
Thank you so much for the five gifts.
Thank you!
I guess we'll do Devil Hunter.
Automat... What is all these settings?
I don't know what they mean.
What is automatic?
Don't just say off.
Tell me what it is.
Oh it auto combos.
The game does moves for you.
So you can have easy mode and then also easier mode.
You can have easy mode and then the easiest mode.
That's for anybody who just wants to mash the buttons and not think, right?
I guess I'll have the tutorial on though.
It's been a minute since I played.
Devil May Cry.
Game reviewer mode?
Probably.
It's so dark I can't see anything.
It's so bright I can't see anything.
Oh no, it's a little cast.
Keep going!
Zoom!
Oh no!
I thought I wasn't on Insano style.
Add to karaoke.
Thank you for the bang.
Yeah, punch that thing!
Are these like the puppet guys?
That like fall from the ceiling?
They look like them.
He's got the beats.
Oh no!
That was his spot, wasn't it?
You're missing it!
Keep going!
You can make it!
Is that Sparta?
Sparta?
Yes?
OK.
It's Papa.
Time to
do a dramatic turn around.
You gotta keep going!
Yeah!
Get out of there!
Oh yeah.
Literally made it for the last note, baby.
She has such low standards.
She was like, at least you tried.
She literally looked at that spot halfway through the song and saw that he wasn't there.
There's no subtitles?
OK, I'll be quiet.
What?
There's subs in the settings?
OK, I'll turn them on after.
What?
He's so similar.
This old man sounds like he's on his last breath.
He's wheezing away.
OK.
Somebody didn't get the memo.
Today is Assassin's Creed cosplay day.
Someone didn't get the memo.
Nero!
I'm out of here.
But it's not over yet.
All this preaching is putting me to sleep.
My controller almost...
He's old!
Finally someone put him out of his misery.
Dante!
Evil Diaz villain arc.
What did the priest do to you?
No, not the present!
Forget about it.
It was just some sticks.
I didn't have time.
I just grabbed some dirt from outside.
That's how cool Dante is when I don't play as him.
He shot him point blank.
How is his face still intact?
Wacky wahoo hobo doesn't kiss pizza.
No pretty girl!
Dante, why are you so evil?
Stop it!
You love women!
Oh, dad!
Woah!
He loves pizza.
Dante looks like that meme of people with blue eyes just staring into your soul.
Is this a tutorial fighting Dante?
Oh, ok.
That'd be crazy.
Why hasn't Dante said anything?
I can't...I don't believe this is him.
He usually...where's his funny one liners?
Oh no.
Oh, nevermind.
What's happening?
Oh, there it is.
Oh no!
Face off against the...Oh no!
The first mission really is fighting Dante!
Oh no!
Oh, this is all so familiar, huh?
I wanna see...Wait, hold on.
Sorry, I'm just looking at stuff.
Ok, Dante.
Damn!
No, no.
Ok, I guess, yeah.
Sorry, spoilers, maybe.
Sorry, sorry.
How do I get out?
Wait, options, here we go.
Subtitles.
On.
Ok, I fixed it.
Can I turn up the brightness just a little bit?
Oh, it's so bright.
What if I played the game like this?
Maybe it's because I have my window open.
I can't see anything.
Ok.
Plus ten should be fine.
Exit.
Ok.
Can I...
There we go.
Select costume.
Oh, you really can change.
Oh wait, it's kind of...Is it similar?
Where like...
You can't really change.
You'd have to do all the missions over again.
But in the new costume.
Oh my god.
I just restart the entire thing, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Ok, we're fine now.
Ok, mission start.
Ok.
Alright.
Telling us how to move.
We love that.
Gun attack.
Ok, I remember that.
You can also fire a gun while in the air.
Yeah, I know that.
Oh yeah,
DMC2.
Oh, it won't let me...
I am attacking!
Can I do the next thing, please?
Oh, I have to attack him like...
I have to attack him a certain number of times.
Ok.
Four.
I have to like, stun lock him that many times.
Ok.
Oh my god, some rorbs!
Ok, I know how to jump.
It won't...It physically will not let me use my sword or anything.
I have to jump to avoid gunfire.
Ok.
So shoot.
Oh.
Oh my god, the rorb looks so scary.
Ok.
Can you shoot again?
So I can get through this tutorial.
Ok, two.
Alright.
He is just standing there.
And jumping.
Ok.
Now what can I do?
Ok, while on the ground...
Press RB sideways.
On LS plus...Ok, side roll.
Oh gosh, ok.
More rorbs please!
Ouch!
Hold on!
More rorbs.
Why is he doing that?
Ouch!
Hold on!
Why is he...Give me the money please.
Thank you.
Are you not entertained?
He is insane.
You shouldn't have done your fancy theatrics.
You lost sight of him.
We got the subtitles.
He is like, oh yeah.
What is this silent treatment?
I don't like it.
Do...Press Y a bunch of times.
Y, Y, Y, Y.
I turned off auto.
That was the first thing I did.
Y, Y, Y, Y, Y.
Alright, I can press the button.
High roller.
While on the ground, press RB back.
Ok, I recognize this.
Come here.
The camera is so nice actually.
Why is it...Wait, I'm so confused.
Every time I press back, it turns me around.
Oh, I have to hold RB.
I'm stupid.
Oh my god.
The lock on.
Oh, that's the lock on.
It looks so funny.
Oh, it didn't hit him.
Stop dodging.
Stop dodging, please.
Please stop dodging me.
Stop dodging me.
There we go.
High roller.
Is that not what I just did?
Angel, thank you so much for the gifted.
I'm gonna start destroying stuff so I can get more roar.
Who needs seats?
His arm!
Just taunting you.
You got a trick up your sleeve.
He speaks!
Are you my papa?
What is happening?
I still have not learned how to balance the music and the speaking.
Buster.
I already know her.
Press B near an enemy.
You can grab an enemy with the devil bringer and toss them like a cheap toy.
Audio mixing is still terrible, yeah.
Oh my god!
Come here, Dante.
Come here.
He's stuck.
Catch this!
Slamma!
Is the game kind now?
It's the tutorial, but I don't have a health bar.
That's insane.
So, you're looking to play, huh?
Alright, I guess I got some time to kill.
He's so calm, cool, collected.
Tough guy, huh?
Oh, I thought that was a monkey.
I'll just turn it up I suppose.
Sorry if the music is loud.
Oh my god.
They're just two peas in a pod.
Oh, there it is.
I spoke too soon, huh?
Wait.
I wanna keep doing this.
Damn, he's so good at dodging, unlike me.
Wait, hold on.
I gotta get my robes, please.
Did he dodge my...
It's really important.
How do I taunt?
Select.
He's got stinger!
No, that's my move!
Please!
Please, that's my move!
No!
Ouch!
Wait, that's how I dodge.
Okay.
Come on, grab him!
What is the... Why is the thing going down?
I wish I could not get stuck in a loop.
Sorry.
I'm getting used to it, guys.
Wait a minute.
Why is it... Is it his health or like... What is it?
Oh, come here!
Stop getting me!
This is health.
Oh.
Is health two?
Interesting.
That's not...
That was way too slow to be...
Almost making him DT.
Wow, how poetic.
Blue?
I think that's kind of...
His clothes remain intact.
That's insane.
Oh my god!
They were demons the whole time.
Adios!
It wasn't me!
Adios, kid.
I'm a tough hunter.
Oh, I found all the rorbs.
Gives me an S, baby.
Proud souls must be expended to obtain new skills.
They can be returned should you decide to unlearn these skills.
Skills can be obtained on the mission start screen as well as the divinity statues found during missions.
I see.
When you're sick, sexy, stylish, your clothes cannot be damaged.
Dang.
When will they introduce, you know...
A clothing damage mechanic.
I thought that's what made this game so great.
Help a lady.
Excited.
She yearns for your touch.
Oh, that was the gift.
Wow, it's so beautiful.
Oh,
sorry.
I do not jest.
Are you a demon too?
You still haven't recovered.
There's no time in duty calls.
Wow, that looks so beautiful on you.
Say something.
I can't pass on an emergency.
I must return to headquarters and report.
I think she was waiting for your compliment.
Duty calls.
Oh.
Oh no, Assassin's Creed.
Oh no!
Where did all these people come from?
It was just so quiet.
Oh yeah.
Get out of here!
I'm never careful.
Kyrie!
Oh no!
It's crying child.
Oh, is she going to die?
Oh no.
He called my name.
Thanks Nero!
I think she's going to die later.
She is.
When do I get to fight him?
Right now.
As it blocks the exit.
Or soon.
I'm doing all of this by the way.
It's not a cutscene.
Oh my god!
Oh my
god!
Mission 2.
How many missions are in this game?
How many...
Wow, I want to see the statue.
Use proud souls to learn... Wait, proud souls?
It's not robes anymore?
I mean it did say earlier use the proud souls.
Oh I have 165!
Red Queen.
That's my sword.
Oh my gosh.
I have like no money.
I could shuffle.
There's so many.
Streak?
Is that...
Is that stinger equivalent?
It's so cheap because I know everybody wants it.
What's the combos?
While on the ground press Y.
Then Y.
Tap Y.
What?
So, slow Y.
I'll buy it.
I like that...
Obtain skill, yes.
I like that if you don't want something...
Or rather if you want the money back you can just unlearn the skill.
That's pretty nice.
Blue rose, I'm guessing that's my gun.
Nope, that's my gun.
Yeah.
Or my arm?
Wait, is it my gun or my arm?
It's my gun.
Just for warrior skills.
Exactly.
Table hopper.
I don't have like any more money.
I'm just kind of seeing what else we got.
These are so expensive.
Get more orbs!
Buy speed.
Yeah, with what money, Jack?
Morbs!
An air hike, how classic.
Enemy step.
In mid-air press A to...
You can just jump on the enemy!
That's so good.
Morbs.
I'm morbing.
Auto skill up.
I don't trust you.
Cancel all.
Cancel all acquired skills and refund.
Oh my goodness, no.
Let's see what items we got.
Okay, vital star.
Holy water is so expensive.
Oh my god.
Blorb.
Classic.
Wait a second, they don't have different faces this time?
That's so sad.
They all look the same.
Wait, Nero's gun is pretty good but you might want to adjust the controls a bit since you have to hold the button to charge it.
I see, I see.
I'll try it out, we'll see.
Head for Fortuna Castle.
Nice.
Map.
Your entry point.
Other doors.
Your current position is shown in the minimap.
Pause menu.
Lock on.
Oh, look at that!
Oh my gosh, it shows how much I have left.
That's so nice actually.
Wait, it's so easy to tell.
Oh my god, there's so many rorbs!
Oh, investigate.
Press B or A to examine suspicious looking areas.
That's the door.
Yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
I'm looking around.
My girlfriend's over there!
And if I destroy these... Sorry, depth of perception.
I get more money.
So that's where I started.
Interesting.
So it shows you where you start?
Why though?
Break.
Do these break?
Everything breaks.
Okay, not everything breaks.
The trash cans!
Someone hid money in the trash can.
Oh yeah, baby!
And then I can sit.
Oh my gosh!
Look at the...
It's like steampunk.
Do these...
We can't destroy the flowers.
Alright, let's go through the door.
Hold on.
What'd you say?
Okay, I learned how to taunt.
It's weird because before I was playing on my Switch.
And now I'm playing PC so it's all different.
L2?
What's that?
I'll try it.
Kick jump.
After jumping press A near a wall.
Okay, double jump.
Woah!
Okay,
that's what that does.
Oh my gosh, I can change the camera angle.
Nice.
Gorb!
Magic golden stone.
Gorb.
Okay, sometimes I can adjust the camera angle.
Money, money, money.
Oh, these are definitely guys.
Max the rev bar and do a stinger?
Okay, I'll try it.
Ryan, thank you so much for the dead gift!
Thank you!
Get your name and welcome to bamboo ship!
They look so awesome though.
I love the design of them.
Oh wow, they look so funky!
Did the door attack me now?
Doors don't attack me anymore.
What?
The time has come!
So am I!
Do they know what that means or...
Is it supposed to mean that or...
Is it...
Do they know?
Happy Sunday!
Oh my gosh, also... Sorry, I'm kind of blocking the map.
Should I like maybe...
Scoot like right here?
It's actually so nice though, because you'll always know where you started and then where you need to go next.
Because yeah, you see the start point down there.
So you don't get lost as much.
Oh my gosh.
Rebellion!
The time has come and so have I.
It's a business district.
These guys mean business.
Party people!
That's where I came from.
Just kidding.
Wait.
Actually, you know what?
The map is confusing.
This is where I came from.
Minto no longer has an excuse when she gets lost.
It's my fault.
I literally just said, oh wow, it's so easy.
And here I am, not knowing anything.
6,000 rorbs!
Exactly.
We got
lots of choices around here.
I want that.
Give me that!
Maybe we jump across or something.
Is this the prison?
Oh my gosh, thank you.
By the way, you can adjust that.
What's this?
It's a candle.
Oh!
Chuni!
Oh my gosh, sorry, I almost missed it.
Is it two?
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Please!
Holding lock on changes an arm attack.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Oh yeah, see, there is a second story.
Hold on.
Maybe I just can't get to it yet.
Chuni, look at the membership!
What the heck?
What the heck is happening?
Not yet.
Oh, I don't think...
Okay, so I don't have it unlocked yet.
Can I jump from like this wall?
Oh no.
Is there a...
There is no hole in the wall.
Spider!
Okay, I guess...
I'll stop.
I'll stop messing around.
Look at...
But there is a star!
Just crawl through, Nero!
It's so weird saying Nero.
It's so weird.
What's this?
Oh, no way.
Is this an elevator?
You'll get used to it.
It's so weird.
I'm so used to saying Dante.
At least with like Metal Gear, I can always say snake and it's right.
Well, except in 2.
Well, technically it's kind of right.
Actually, he originally was a snake.
And then they changed his codename to Raiden.
Victor, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
I think I just got the thing you were telling me to do.
Evil legacy!
Unleash the tentacles.
Is there like crazy fanart of this or what?
Has the ability to awaken a new power within.
Yeah, it does.
Someone saw that and something was awakened within them too.
Hellbound.
Lock on to Gr... Grim... Grip.
Sorry, I can't say that well.
Lock on...
Sorry.
Oh my god.
This is like triggering my stutter.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Hold on.
I have a bit of a stutter sometimes.
And if I... If it like gets activated, I can't...
It gets worse, you know.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Grippy.
I'm just gonna say the grippy.
While standing on a continuum pad.
And press B.
Sorry.
That was embarrassing.
Lock on.
Grippy.
Fun!
Okay.
Hit the grippy.
Nero's VA voice is Dante.
I didn't know that at all.
I don't know some... I've been trying to avoid like spoilers of stuff, you know.
Not to say that that's a spoiler, but...
I don't even know who Nero, this guy is.
This is all new to me.
Don't say lock on to a... Don't say that.
Don't say that.
I'm... Dang it.
Nero.
Why?
Nero, why?
Can I get baited?
Why is this jump suck so much?
Use the grippy.
You can't there, no?
You can only use it on the... on the launch pads?
It's right there within my grasp.
Wait, how do I get the things below me?
And like the cells and stuff.
You can use it wherever?
You can?
What?
Wait a second.
Then...
My god!
Is there anything else in here?
Oh!
Thank you for explaining.
Backseaters are like so proud of themselves right now.
They're like, yeah, we told her the thing and it worked.
We did it!
She listened to our instructions and it succeeded.
Crazy.
Oh, is that a wall?
Okay, I guess that's a wall.
Secret... Oh, come on.
Don't explain the secret mission.
Examining certain areas within a stage can reveal the existence of secret missions.
Remember, suspicion is the precipice of enlightenment.
VTuber listened!
I guess we'll check it out.
Finally, the time has come and so have I.
Destroy all demons within the time limit.
Okay, I'll try.
I'm not really good at these though.
Dang, he's tough.
I'm just gonna keep stingering him.
There we go.
Oh no!
That thing seems pretty...
pretty strong.
Oh,
I have to remember to like...
Oh, grab him.
Oh, no.
Grab
him.
Grab him.
Okay, and then grab him.
And then grab him.
I see.
You're streaking him.
Oh yeah, Nero's a streaker, not a stinger.
That was the last one.
Should we try again?
Let's try one more time.
I'm learning with the arm too.
You can grab him and then you can throw him.
You grab him, you lock on, you grab him and then you unlock and you throw him.
And it's powerful, it seems.
More so than streaking on him.
Hey,
I did it!
Blow up fragment!
VTuber, those combos are not optimal.
My bad.
VTuber...
The time has come and so has...
I can't believe those are the actual lyrics.
I can't believe it.
But I can also believe it.
Devil may cry.
Oh no!
Who am I fighting here?
I don't know how to feel about the webbies.
I don't know why I was doing that.
Slam dunk!
Not even SSS, VTuber.
I know, gosh.
The worst to ever do it.
How can she ever think about even playing a video game?
I can't believe she even attempts.
Snatch!
I'm so ahead of this game.
I'm just so...
Come here.
I can't believe those are the lyrics.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Devil may come.
Oh my gosh, Jack, thank you so much for the pink.
Mint, that's me!
How'd you know?
How'd you know that's my name?
Looking forward to the karaoke of Nero's theme.
Nero is kind of freaky.
One thing I'm not good at doing is like that.
The little dodges, you know.
Because, okay, my...
It's like camera specific.
Are they still down there?
I'm trying to see.
There's no one there.
I hear laughter.
No one's down there.
Oh, bar.
Okay.
The party moved on.
Where do all the hip kids hang out now?
I'm in the residential district.
Very cool.
Oh.
Red Queen's fuel injection system igniting a special propellant along the blade that propels the next attack to new heights of power.
Three maximum levels of power.
Did I mess it up?
I think I did.
Wait, I think I messed it up.
Oh, hello.
No, you... Wait, how do I change...
Uh-oh.
There it is.
I don't know how to change targets yet.
Click
in the left stick?
I just tried that, but it didn't work.
I'll try it again.
Click the stick?
Right stick?
Okay, I'll try right stick instead.
Try it next time.
Little tiny room.
Follow... It's like a candy rorb.
Candy line of rorbs.
Which way do I go?
Follow the rorbs.
I'm greedy.
I'm greedy!
It pays to be greedy, baby.
Follow the candy.
Candy!
Yo, I have so much money.
I might be good at this game or something.
Thank you for the pink!
Wait, what was that about Kyria?
This is just like one of my Japanese anime.
Otnim.
Thank you so much for the pink, Dr. Cranberry.
Time is coming, so am I.
I'm gonna get like the worst grade on this mission.
Because I'm taking my time.
Sorry, I don't always take my time on things, you know me.
If you've never watched me before, this is just how I play.
I like to run around and be a little silly.
I'm no speed runner.
I'm a slow runner.
The man in the red coat headed off towards the coast.
To get there, you're going to have to lower the drawbridge.
Slow walk.
You're my favorite DMC Vtuber.
I know there's a few people that I've played, but...
I think...
Roar.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm glad you think that my enthusiasm is fine.
You!
I'm too good.
Look at the membership.
Keto, thank you for that gifted wire.
There's so many gifted memberships today.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, there is a membership stream right after this stream.
Oh my gosh.
You guys are going to have to remember... Wait.
It's only been like an hour.
Okay, good.
Wait, what time is my membership stream at today?
5?
In 4... Not 4 hours.
In 3 hours.
Okay.
I might get into this, you know, and then forget.
Just maybe towards the time of this next stream, remind me.
The time has not come, so I haven't either.
That's the new song.
Pyrobug, thank you for the funny outfit!
Teacup, thank you for the...
You can throw down bosses?
Oh, hell yeah!
I don't care about stylish rank!
Oh, I thought that said daddy.
Like, ready, but with a D.
I was about to be like, I don't think that's a word.
Are you daddy?
Puzzle time!
Oh my gosh, I love puzzles.
One thing I thought about playing recently is Catherine.
Because I've heard it's just puzzles.
And I'm kind of interested.
K-Saber, thank you for the 5 gift cards!
That was the puzzle?
Oh, okay.
I saw that it was on the Steam sale, so...
I've never played it before though.
But it's timed puzzles.
I see.
Interesting.
Oh, just kidding.
The time has come and I still need a few more minutes.
I'm kind of sleepy.
This doesn't always happen.
Dang it!
Gosh, he's just like Dante.
I love it!
It's just like a spitting image of him.
A drawbridge.
Gun fixes everything.
Exactly.
Can I just jump down from here?
No?
Okay.
Lollipop, chainsaw, no more heroes are all great games.
Oh yeah!
Lollipop, chainsaw I've actually played a little bit of before, but I never finished it.
Stylish rank matters more in this game since you buy skills with Proud Souls now instead of rewards.
Don't say that!
Oh no!
Wait, I'm lost.
There's the door.
Oh, wait.
I'm trying to... I can't get the camera... There it is.
What the hell is it locking on to?
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
Grab!
Grabby grab!
Grabby grab him!
Hello?
There we go.
That was weird.
I keep only getting C's.
They get degrees though.
C's get... Proud... Proud... Solis.
Solis.
Oh, my arm was too short.
Taunting helps.
That's right!
Thank you for the reminder.
Your timing is impeccable.
Fix up your moves?
I try!
I only have a few skills though.
I have Y, Y, Y, Y.
I have backwards Y.
I have... I don't have Y, pause, Y, pause, Y.
My guns too.
Will that increase it?
It's OK.
Taunt!
Why am I pulling them all towards me?
Ouchie, ouchie.
I still only get C's.
I got B's at one point, but...
Chat is now back to the tutorial.
No, it's OK.
I like reminders.
OK, but you don't have to be mean, OK guys?
I'm still...
Taunting in the air.
You don't have to be mean though.
It's new.
There's new controls.
OK, I'll get used to it eventually.
Doesn't seem very safe.
What is that?
Well, I went down here.
Even though it didn't seem very safe.
Air taunts are only DMC5.
You guys can't taunt.
Yeah, you can't.
I couldn't even do it.
You guys can't tell me to do something and it's the wrong information!
Oh, I see how it is.
What is this?
Nothing?
OK, it's nothing.
Woah.
Big orb.
Divinity statue!
An ominous power resides in this mysterious statue.
If the blood of a demon is sacrificed to it, the power will be released.
But I can only buy with orbs.
I guess I don't really need anything then.
Since I can only buy with the soul things, right?
Destroy it?
Can you?
Oh, the style statue.
I'm not there yet.
Oh my gosh!
You guys are...
I just need to calm down, OK?
You need to calm down with telling me what to do, OK?
You need to calm down.
I'm spritzing you right now with the water bottle.
Calm down.
Chat, calm down!
Calm down!
What the...
She's so sexy.
If the power is what you desire, it is with your skills you shall inspire.
That's what they look like now.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even...
I guess...
What do you want me to get?
Ah!
I got it.
Finally.
This is like the longest mission ever.
This don't look so good.
Hello?
Anybody home?
Are you living in this universe with Sugg?
No!
Nero is so unphased.
So me too.
Me too then.
I'm unphased.
Not the casual walk, but...
I'm gonna rev up, baby.
I'm gonna rev up.
Curious.
Same.
Dumb ectoplasm.
I'm basically jelly.
2000 years ago.
Where were you when Dante was going and doing stuff?
This guy is a nobody.
I keep wasting my revs because I don't know how to use it yet.
Ouch!
I tried to do that, but I didn't.
I don't know how to rev very well.
How do
you do the rev?
No!
My arm was too short!
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
My health!
I'm gonna die!
I do have a vital star.
Maybe I should use it.
Might be stupid, but...
I feel like I'm so close with him.
Let's just try it.
I'm gonna ignore the revving up for now because it makes it so I can't move.
OK.
Alright.
I'm gonna get back into it.
Please!
My arm!
I wasted the star, you guys.
I totally wasted the star!
It's good!
No!
Don't block you asshole!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Let's bust her.
Oh no!
Phase 2?
Oh no, he's gone.
Oh yeah!
Someone did say you can grab him earlier.
That's right.
I'll try the grab next time.
First try!
Don't worry about the vital star.
Juni, I have no advice, but thank you for the Aqua Super.
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
Yeah, what star?
Exactly.
I don't like that the...
What?
That part is inverted, but...
Can I go in here?
No?
OK.
Through here we go.
Oh, that was the orbs.
But I still got a B for stylish points.
B for style.
That's not so bad.
It's not so bad.
The white wing.
Search for Tuna Castle.
Alright.
Let's power up, baby.
Snatch!
Should I make my snatch longer?
He's so snatched.
Tuna Castle.
What did I say?
Wait, what are you saying?
Snatch has another meaning?
I thought, like, snatched was like when you...
You have, like, your waist is so small.
It's snatched.
It's boomer slang?
What does it mean?
Wait, so it means coochie and boomer?
You guys are always joking about my age, but I hear you guys being like...
The old wench said, speaketh of the snatch.
How uncouth.
You guys are calling yourselves out.
You guys are calling yourselves out for your age.
Very unladylike.
Maiden Mint, how dareth you utter such terrible speakings?
Just because you're old doesn't mean I'm not also old.
I don't know.
I didn't know what that meant.
I didn't know.
You're out here.
You're literally a caveman.
You're like Oonga Boonga.
VTuber.
VTuber say.
Silly word.
Oonga Boonga.
Literally, literally like cave drawing right here.
You're like... You're drawing symbols and runes on the walls.
Ye maiden mint doth proclaim thy looted scripts.
Oonga Boonga.
Anyway, what else we got?
Let's see.
Red Queen combo.
Y Y, then Y Y Y Y.
Y Y Y.
Midair, press Y Y, then Y.
Exceed.
Increasing the X gauge to 2 slots allows you to access level 2 exceed moves.
Oh, this is the gauge.
Okay.
What's that blue bar underneath?
I don't have that.
What's that?
It's pre-Victorian slang.
That's what I was saying.
Wine or whiskey.
They just get better with age and maturity.
For revving, just tap it in between swings.
I wasn't sure if you hold it down or tap it, but tapping seems to be the best way.
Because you hold it down and it only gets you so much.
This is coat made of denim.
I don't know actually.
We got the splits.
Caliber.
Woah.
And the shuffle.
And what else was there?
Oh, blue rose is my gun.
Oh yeah.
Wait, I don't have charge shot, so...
Abilities.
We could become faster.
Which could be good, I think.
Get more orbs.
Morbs!
Speed.
Speed is mandatory?
Oh really?
Then I'll get speed.
Oh, sorry.
We'll get speed and we can also maybe get...
There's something else.
No?
What was it?
A devil bringer?
A snatch!
We could get both.
Maybe.
I feel like I use snatch so much.
Combo 2.
What was combo 2?
Oh, Y.
Then Y.
Let's get snatch 2 first.
I keep doing that.
Oh, sorry.
Maybe this is OK for now.
Mission start!
What's in here?
Hello?
I
keep seeing daddy.
So effortlessly even.
Oh, OK.
Let's go to the other side first.
Daddy.
Actually,
I kind of like that they split up the currency.
So now I can buy a bunch of items.
I can buy a bunch of items and I don't have to decide whether I split between abilities or stuff.
I actually kind of really appreciate that.
Items casual.
I can't believe you use items with the world map.
That didn't work out as I thought it would.
I should have grabbed it.
I knew I was going to do that eventually.
I knew I was going to call Dante at some point.
Where am I?
I can't see.
OK, I give up.
I have a lot of Rorb.
It's fine.
I can miss a Rorb.
I won't cry about it.
I got him.
Oh, practice my revs.
OK.
New mechanic.
I got to get used to it.
I got to get...Oh my god.
Him running.
The speed thing is so strange.
He starts so slow and then goes fast.
What if Mito had a princess dress on?
What do you mean by that?
Battlestar!
Taunt while speeding?
What just happened?
The Rorb you left is my dad.
Sorry for your dad.
Oh no!
Grab it!
I didn't actually mean to do that, so it kind of worked out perfectly.
Yeah!
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Please, Nero!
I can't see anything!
Platforming is my worst enemy.
Maybe I wouldn't be good at Catherine then if you guys say it's a platformer.
OK.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
Wait.
The camera angles are awkward.
They are a little...
Oh, I see.
What the...
But it doesn't go anywhere.
Or does it?
Am I crazy?
Hold on.
Oh!
Wait, I think I saw it.
Two!
Joined 15 minutes ago.
Never played a Devil May Cry game.
Who is Dan, Tit, and Nero?
Last hit of each combo is what gives a lot of style, so you should finish them.
Finish what?
OK.
We are going to have to wall jump.
I see it in my sights.
OK.
Hold on.
We got this.
This is great practice though, no?
Huh?
I'm so confused actually.
I can't jump in the air, so what do I do?
Should have farmed for air hike.
True.
Oh, shit.
No, this is not...
This is not a hot dog moment.
It's pretty perfect.
I don't think I can get it, no?
I don't think I can get it.
Please!
Why can't we use ladders?
I know!
Can you move me there?
No, it won't let me.
Or, I'm trying.
I'm pressing left.
Oh, gosh!
And then if I can't jump, I fall back.
I feel like giving up.
Please!
See, I can't jump there, so...
I...
I've personally heard a group of blokes in year 10s say to my... What is this?
Excuse me, I can't understand your accent.
A group of blokes in year 10s say to my English teacher, I can smell your snatch from here.
You smell like a fresh fish market.
Okay, let's just keep going.
Maybe we can come back.
Maybe once I have air height.
Oh, I'm silly.
There we go.
Oh, it's cold.
Oh, I'm cold!
Is this gonna... Okay.
Oh my god, the camera angle is killing me.
Please!
Blimey!
The moon is beautiful.
So beautiful.
Does this break?
No, not everything breaks.
Yeah.
Does this break?
No.
What constitutes is... It's gotta be real skinny.
Gotta be a real skinny guy.
Did you guys see the blood moon?
I didn't realize it was a blood moon when I did see it.
I was like, wow, blood moon!
I don't think we are going back actually.
Maybe we can go back for the blorb.
Ah man.
It was cloudy.
Oh no!
Sparta?
Papa?
Nope, just normal enemy.
Holy shit!
He does sound like he's saying hop to us sometimes, I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah!
You okay?
There's so many things that break in this game.
It's fine.
I wish the whole game was stoic.
It actually fits the aesthetic so well.
Where am I going?
Where did I come from?
Map!
Do I go this way?
Okay, there's a door down here.
What's the other way?
Cotton eyed Joe.
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Cotton eyed Joe.
Anything up here?
No.
I've been married a long time ago.
Can I not go this way anymore?
This way?
The game is telling me I'm an idiot.
Oh maybe...wait, does this just go back?
Oh, I'm backtracking.
Oh okay, but we know now that we can.
Okay, perfect.
Orlando, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay, cool.
Here I thought I wouldn't be able to.
Mr. Orange, I appreciate it, but please don't...
Spoil...
If I come to a story thing, I will...
I will listen.
Please guys, try to refrain from being like, okay this thing is coming up.
Wait a second.
Wait a minute.
A maiden.
Madame.
I like her tail.
So close.
Oh my god, I'm getting out my magnifying glass.
Enhance!
Slow motion!
Ask and you shall receive!
Nice.
I did, I did.
I helped you.
You saw everything?
You're welcome.
Gosh, I love Devil May Cry and their little grates that are way too big.
Anyone's foot would slip right through.
Charmed!
Oh.
He's shy!
Shy boy.
He says, ma'am, I have a girl.
Ma'am, I'm betrothed.
What's her eye color?
She's not your sister.
What's up with this little section?
I understand the importance of that scene now.
Hello darkness, my old friend.
I liked the plot.
Yes, thank you.
Looking kind of familiar.
Yeah, just a little.
What the hell is this?
Hello?
You do not have the power to destroy this rusted coffin.
Only that which makes an impact will break it.
Yeah, I did.
Just kidding.
Do you like the plot?
Yep.
I like the plot.
What is this thing?
Nothing?
Okay.
Really?
Maybe I should buy some lore.
How much more does it... What does it go to?
10,000?
5,000!
Okay, not bad.
Why not?
I wanna... I'll get some more holy water too.
3 out of 6 though.
Yeah, it's actually not so bad.
Oh my god.
Did you only think of that because of...
Never played DMC4.
I hope you feel better soon!
That sucks!
Feel better, feel better.
Oh, how spooky this place...
Remember how I said we were gonna get that money back?
I hate chairs!
Sitting's for bums!
I have no ass!
If I can't sit, no one can!
Sorry.
I wanted to get all the chairs.
How much money is it?
Oh, not that.
8,000!
Nice.
Okay.
I don't... Can we wall jump up to there or no?
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
I didn't think... I didn't know if it would hurt me or what.
So let's go in here.
Just kidding, that isn't...
No, just kidding.
We'll go...
It says it's a door though.
You can see it on the map.
That's a wall.
No, you guys, look, look, look!
You see it on the map?
On the map it shows a little orange thing.
Oh, it's upstairs.
That's so confusing!
Did I get another...
I can't remember what skill I got.
Let's just keep going.
Where are you?
No, my arm is too short!
Come here!
Yeah, we need the long snatch.
The longest snatch.
What's this?
Special seal lies over the enormous door.
An inscription on the table reads...
Collect the four statues and open the way to the arena.
The arena!
Okay.
I like how it gives you a...
Hello?
Where?
Whoops!
No.
Oh, there.
Okay, there's so much...
There's so much here.
I'm feeling like we're...
This place is humongous!
Which way do I go?
Oh my god, this place is humongous!
There's so many doors!
I have to start at one.
A gyro blade is enshrined beyond this obstacle.
Only that which makes an impact will remove the obstacle.
Oh, this is the thing, like the coffin, right?
Let's go back to whence we came.
There's so many doors!
Okay, so
there was...
This is where I came from.
Right there.
And inside, there's more stuff in there.
And I can't get in.
Anything down here?
Oh, what's that?
That looks mysterious.
No?
A painting of nothing.
Okay, let's go into the first door.
Door number one.
Yes!
There's so many things to destroy.
It's your birthday!
Your two favorite game series, Metal Gear and Devil May Cry.
Keep being awesome.
Thank you!
Wait, he'll die.
Okay, I thought I could destroy those.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Major Reception!
Happy birthday!
Yeah!
Hallway.
Wait!
Is this not...
The thing that we need?
What is this?
To proceed further, the power to repel fire must be obtained.
A gyro blade.
Is it a gyro blade or a gyro blade?
I can't tell.
It can be used as a shield.
Okay, playing baseball again.
I can't do this yet, I don't think.
Alright!
Next door.
To explore.
Can't go through the Colosseum door yet.
All the way down here.
There's this door.
Let's go one at a time, baby!
I took two steps!
I
don't know if me doing my gun really does much, to be honest.
We got an A!
Atomic!
Gun is for combo extensions or charge shots.
Yeah, I don't have the charge shot yet.
So...
Onwards.
No, no, no, what's this?
You do not have the power to destroy this rusted statue, only that would make an...
I can't do any of this stuff!
I don't like that.
Wait, I really don't like this.
I know you guys are probably like, Rev, please, Rev!
I'll learn eventually, I promise.
Maybe.
Somehow.
I'll do it eventually.
Oh,
man.
Yeah, I'll rev now.
I'll rev now.
Oh, it's this room again!
Do I have to do like a... I didn't do anything there.
Hold it longer.
She's locked and loaded, baby.
Will it go away?
You can rev while attacking?
It stays?
Oh, shoot.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, I think...
Okay, do I have to be really quick about getting the other one or else it disappears?
You can shoot while you rev.
Oh my gosh.
This...
Oh!
What the hell just hit me?
What did I do?
I'm getting all my practice in.
But
it's not doing anything!
It's not doing anything!
I'm like alternating, but I even still can't do that.
What?
I did it a few times.
Yeah, I didn't notice, but I don't know how I did it.
I don't know how I did it.
I don't want to keep doing this over and over again.
We gotta lock in.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, I am getting lots of money.
That's the truth.
Roar farming.
What is this?
Almost platforming.
Pseudo-platforming.
But it seems like you just kinda have to let it happen.
You just gotta kinda let... You gotta just kinda do it and let it do it's thing.
Maybe?
Okay.
Only that one.
Alright.
Which ones disappear?
I'm checking.
Okay.
I did it!
Where am I?
I'm upstairs!
Where the barrier was.
I think I have to go to the little ghosties room.
Hello?
No.
Missing air hike right now.
Oh, okay.
I have to go to the little ghosties room.
I'm gonna also get some tea.
Or some more water.
Tea or water.
I don't know.
Everybody stretch.
That felt good.
Okay.
Tea or water.
Everybody get some... get some...
Get some water or something.
Okay, very good.
Did you wash your hands?
Everybody.
Come back.
Let's go.
Sorry, I didn't realize that the music was completely off.
Just sitting here in silence.
My cat's in here, so inevitably I will have to let her out in like two minutes probably.
There was nothing else, right?
It was just this hall.
Oh, besides the... besides the roar.
That I don't know how to get to.
Maybe from here?
No.
Yeah, it's pies.
She loves to come in here.
Run!
So fast.
What the?
Oh, it's these guys again.
Come in.
Can I grab you?
Yeah!
That's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to...
Where are you?
The time has come and so have I.
Freak.
Oh, Freak Phantom of the Wise!
What is your daily wisdom?
Before drinking your hot tea...
Take at least... or...
Blow at least five times.
This place is so huge!
I don't know where I am.
I'm so lost.
Everything is so confusing.
This feels like the longest mission in history.
Is this game so much longer?
Oh wait, I can get that with a grab.
No?
I'm just stupid?
Why is this mission so long then?
What was the point of this area?
By your hand you cannot break our clasp.
That power lies in another grasp.
Oh, clasp.
Wait, did I say clasp?
What do I need?
Later?
Ok, I'll come back.
Am I... I don't even remember what the mission... Oh, the mission is like what?
Explore or whatever?
Well, I'm exploring.
I'm exploring the castle.
Thank you!
Catch this!
Nero got that CQC.
Yeah, I do.
Ok, now I'm on the other side.
Alright, we're still exploring.
This is a thing.
Alright, I have performed a function.
Wait, did I?
Oh, there we go.
I completed the function.
The door that confused me earlier.
Screw you door!
Oh my god,
I'm stuck at this.
Come
on, I want S!
Please!
I was so close.
I was so close!
The taunts...
There's too much to remember!
Rev, taunt, style, dis, wow, jump, scream, yell, excite, duel, jump, rev, style, taunt...
There's too much!
There's too much.
Hold on, my chat broke.
Give me one second.
Hold on.
Dante.
Brooding in the corner.
Do I not need this thing?
I'm not gonna remember my way around here.
What is this?
Oh, it's one of you.
I couldn't tell what it was from the side.
Wait, I do need to go back down here.
And go through, just kidding, through here!
Okay.
Making progress, I suppose.
Hey,
stop.
I'm self-conscious.
I am the demon.
Can you not tell?
Why would you turn your back on him?
The book stopped my knowledge!
Yeah, I do that too.
I rev.
Oh, I need to parry.
Wait, I got an achievement, but...
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
I'm trying to parry, but...
Oh, there's more!
Oh gosh, I wish I had air height right now!
Oh, I did it!
I
like that you can just...
You can do whatever that was with their sword.
Is that the thing I needed?
Am I gonna become all powerful?
Brutal!
Give me some orbs, please.
This looks like I can...
Oh, nice.
Thank you, game.
Oh, give me my money.
So, once I get that, I should be able to...
Be for bananas!
Oh, there we go.
What is it?
What is this?
Yummy.
It's herb.
So if you put it in that, does it ignite it and make it move?
Anime!
Anime.
Oh, sorry.
Anima Mercury!
An artificial soul made using alchemy breathes life into the anima.
Oh my god, this one hour mission is finally over.
It was only 35 minutes?
You guys, I got an A on stylish points.
That's huge for me.
Yippee!
What time is it?
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
That felt like the longest mission ever in the history of the world.
Use your newly earned powers to gather the four gyro yuro blades.
What should we learn?
Or should we...
Save up.
It does kind of suck that I have to wait over and over and over again.
Air hike, I don't have the money.
Save up for air hike then maybe.
It's pronounced like hero.
So yuro.
It's not gyro.
How are you ever supposed to know the difference?
Oh yeah, if I were to get like a new combo.
To get more style points.
Then that would potentially get me more soul stuff.
And then we could re-find later.
That's how you play the game, huh?
I feel like I need an in-air thing.
Because I do like the...
The one that puts them in the air and then I feel like I'm...
So I'm going to try this.
I do this every time.
Grab that and then...
Oh, I don't have enough for streak 2.
No!
That spin is stylish.
Stylish!
Caliber is an air thing.
What's this one?
I don't have enough for this one either.
Shoot.
Well, then I will do...
We'll do combo C.
Because...
Actually...
Yeah, we'll do combo C.
We'll try it.
Caliber is good.
Should I have gotten that one?
Oh yeah, it's fine.
It's fine.
What's that one again?
I find myself probably using this one more.
Y, Y, pause, then Y.
Y, Y, pause, Y.
Okay.
Yeah, it's an aerial stinger.
That's crazy.
Sorry, I know I keep looking.
I keep going back and forth.
Y, Y, then Y, Y, Y, Y.
Y, Y, Y, Y, Y.
Alright.
Blorb, you know it.
You know it, baby.
Or do I get a holy water?
Or like...
We can get the holy waters once we max out the blorb.
Because blorb...
Like, it's permanent.
Okay.
But why?
I don't know, actually.
Mito paste.
Thank you!
Alright.
Alive.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
What the hell?
What?
You can build up... wait.
By striking the euro blade with your sword before moving it with the buster, you can build up energy and release a huge destructive force.
So basically we've created a new weapon.
So if I'm like...
Maybe...
Oh, I missed it entirely.
I missed it.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Euro is the food.
Gyro is the mechanism.
So you don't want to eat it.
Well, everybody kept saying it's a euro!
Everybody, it wasn't me!
Oh, dang it.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna do this.
I thought it was gyro because it was the way it...
I was like, yeah, like a gyroscope.
No?
Aww.
No, I can't take you with me.
So sad.
Wait, what's this?
Is there a second level?
Maybe I can crash this door?
Oh.
Oh my gosh, it's so powerful.
Okay.
Eh?
I can't fit maybe.
How do I get in?
Is it...
Is it upstairs?
I don't see anything up there though.
Oh wait, yeah.
I don't...
Eh?
You guys see the map?
I guess it's nothing.
But what's the map for then?
It's a later mission.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh yeah.
Again.
Oh my gosh, it's this guy!
Why are the ice men in here?
What was the combo again?
I don't...
Shoot, I don't remember.
It was...
Why?
Wait,
wait, hold on.
I need you to go in here.
Stop turning around!
Oh, I have to lock on, that's why.
I'm silly.
Oh, he doesn't go in the air.
Why?
Wait, what was it?
I don't think I did it right.
Ouch!
Why?
Okay.
Tell me why.
Unleash him!
Did we take you home with us?
Oh wait, I could have used you in battle.
Okay.
He's in harmony with that blue coffin.
The coffin must be summoning a...
Gyro.
It wants a blade!
A blade!
Oh, that's upstairs.
That's a wall.
I've learned my lesson.
Where is one though that we can summon?
Oh farming, oh farming, oh farming.
Farming for rorbs.
Every day I'm farming for rorbs.
Oh farming, oh farming, oh farming.
How I love the farming.
Every day, every way, I'm farming, I'm farming, I'm farming.
It's a respectable job.
Someone's got a door.
Someone's got to clean the door.
Oh here we go.
Okay.
Little girl, hold on.
Don't go over there.
Please don't go over there.
Hold on, I've got to stop my cat from causing mischief.
Hey!
Stop it!
Stop!
Little girl, you're so sweet.
Did you run out?
Okay, hold on.
Let me let my cat out.
Okay.
She always tries to jump on top of the pachinko machine.
So I have to be like, don't do that.
I have to be like, no ma'am.
Wait on.
Yay!
First try.
What's this?
Oh.
The seal is quite peculiar.
The magical power within is palpable, but there is no hope of controlling it.
Oh, okay.
Old Mint Donald had a...
Oh, stop!
Stop!
I'm trying to get away.
And on that farm she has some rorbs.
E-I-E-I-O.
With a brown brown here and a brown brown there.
Here's a brown, there's a brown everywhere.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Where do I go from here then?
I guess we...
Were there any doors on this side that I haven't tried?
I mean, obviously I know that there's like a...
Oh yeah, there's this door here.
There was other stuff that we can do now because we have...
I'm in the torture chamber.
Okay, awesome.
Nevermind, not awesome.
Not awesome!
No,
it keeps getting worse!
Dash!
Did you hear the achievement?
Yippee!
I don't need to be back in here, do I?
This is where...
Why was there...
Oh wait.
Okay, we need a thing.
Aww.
The fireball room.
Where was that?
Okay, so it is left click.
Alright, cool.
I don't need to do the puzzle again, but if I fall I have to fight all the guys again.
So I'm just gonna do the puzzle.
I'm just gonna do the puzzle so that...
First floor?
It was?
I can just leave?
I guess that's true.
This is so much easier.
Wait.
How do I leave?
What was this room?
What was this area?
I don't remember.
Hold on.
Sorry guys, I'm trying to get my bearings.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
That's what that tunnel was.
Alright, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
This door?
What was this door?
Did I go through this door?
There's too many doors.
Reacting in an unknown manner.
Oh, I should have...
I should have gone in here first.
Oh!
I sequence broke a little bit.
Oopsie!
Oh, and then...
This is...
Is this the fire... This is the fireball room.
No, it's not.
lol
This is the fireball room?
Yes!
Yes.
Oh no, it's these guys.
Nice!
Progress!
Somehow, we finally made some progress, maybe.
Well, we're getting there, we're getting there.
This area is just so big.
It's so big!
My little brain can't keep up.
And I actually have a pretty decent sense of direction.
So...
OK, there's the fireball.
OK, so how do I deflect it?
Oh!
lol I see.
No, I do actually, you guys!
I actually do have a good sense of direction.
You guys just don't think I do.
Oh!
lol It's true though!
Can I get behind him?
Secret.
Let's go away.
What's the secret?
Successfully execute a mid-air buster five times without touching the ground.
What's a mid-air buster?
lol I like how it's called ALU.
Oh.
How?
I've touched the ground so easily though.
Wait.
Immediately, like, I haven't done a single one.
What am I doing wrong?
No, no, hold on.
I'm trying to do...
No!
How many are you?
Where are you?
Wait, hold on.
Come on, go in the air.
Wait, do I have to...
Oh, I think...
Okay, I'm just grabbing it, but...
Okay, hold on.
Oops.
Ah!
See?
Okay, nevermind.
I give up.
That?
Without hitting the ground?
Hell no.
At least I was able to do it though.
I did one.
And this is why I basically never do the secret missions.
At least you know how you can air grab now.
I know, right?
We learned.
Oh, ouch.
Damn, I keep trying.
I'm not very good at it.
There we go, yeah!
Oh, wait.
Slam dunk!
Rev, rev, rev, rev, rev, rev.
Rev, rev, rev, rev, rev, rev, rev.
So you have to rev it at the same time as hitting?
Basically...
Maybe I'm not doing it right though.
I'm glad the doors don't attack you anymore.
It's like a rhythm game.
I'll have to keep practicing with it.
I'll have to keep practicing.
Gosh, this game is so generous.
With rorbs and grorbs and grorbs and everything.
Wait, this thing.
Yeah, the chairs are...
The chairs are evil.
What are you guys doing?
I don't know where I just unleashed that upon.
Let's try and bowl.
I can't see anything, please.
Yes!
He's dead depth.
This guy is...
This guy has 9 lives.
Almost a strike.
I know, we got a couple of them, right?
Oh no, I'm trying to...
Do the...
Wait a minute.
Holy cow.
I have to get used to...
Yay!
I'm trying to explain my thoughts.
Hold on.
I don't know what the combo is called.
The one...
This one.
Sometimes, like when the camera angle changes...
I can't tell if it's like hold back on the L...
Depending on where I'm facing or where the camera is.
Oh, you need to lock...
I keep forgetting to lock.
My brain is not it today.
Sorry guys.
I only got like a little bit of sleep.
Sorry.
Oh wait.
Okay, so now that we have that one, how do we get this one?
Do I go in here?
No, this leads back...
Brain not brainin'.
It's where the character is facing.
Which I have trouble with too, no worries.
I'm glad that you can relate then.
But this game is already feeling...
I mean...
I have yet to die, so...
This game is already a massive...
Massive...
I don't want to say improvement, but...
It is so much kinder.
A relief.
Truly.
And I'm having so much fun with it.
Where do I go?
Is it where we came from?
If anybody knows, can I get a hint?
This is the fireball room.
I already have one.
This one?
Oh, I can just let him...
Oh, I thought he was stuck there.
Okay, just kidding.
Oh...
Okay.
That makes things a whole lot easier.
There we go.
What did I release?
Nice.
I like how this is probably the intended way...
To get rid of these guys in this moment.
This is so awesome.
Triple strike, baby!
Where did it go?
Oh, there it is.
Hello?
There we go.
Alright, let's go get the other one.
A turkey?
Is that where the triple strike is?
Maybe?
One space remains...
And we got it.
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
Babe load.
Go!
What did I...
What did it just break?
I heard...
I heard crashing.
I can't believe...
It's so crazy that Beyblade has kind of made like a comeback.
Have you guys noticed that too?
The Beyblade comeback?
Oh, too much power.
Too much power.
It's fun though.
Yippee!
We did it!
Golly.
What else can I buy?
Not even close.
I'll buy holy water.
Metal gear?
Get the photo camera ready.
Little fairies.
Oh my god.
They're making out.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, yes they are.
Oh my god.
Holy show.
They're so hot.
I was enjoying the show.
How can I grab you?
Slapdunk!
Can I grab you?
Still hot!
Nevermind.
Yeah.
Say it, don't spray it buddy.
Oh my god.
Can I grab you?
I'm gonna try and grab him.
Oh, damn.
Can I grab him?
I can grab when he's stunned.
No!
Is this stunned or...
Do I need to stun him?
Oh, it's the hot ladies.
Again?
Just kidding.
No?
Oh, yes they are.
Can I grab you?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Did I get eaten?
I think I'm getting eaten.
I can just hear him going like...
Ouch, ouch.
Where did he go?
Oh, hot ladies again.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die in here.
Oh my god.
I don't want to get caught by you.
It's so bad if I do...
Attack them fast.
These guys?
Where did they go?
Okay.
Wait, is he stunned?
No.
Oh my god, I jumped.
I jumped but too late.
That sucks.
You guys!
I'm like doing so little damage to him though.
Not a lot at all.
I think I'm not gonna make it.
I gotta be a little bit more aggressive.
No bad touch.
I will die, I will die.
It will be the end of me.
Damn.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
It's okay.
I'm okay for sure.
What do you guys think?
Do I waste the gorb?
We could gorb.
Why not use it?
Is this it?
Oh, wait.
Holy shit.
I didn't get a single...
We got him!
We got him boys.
We got him.
Yeah!
That was crazy.
Oh my god, her toes.
No, her toes.
That's exactly what I think.
Oh yeah!
We absorbed the sexy lady.
She's always a part of us.
Baby!
Brothers.
Did he just say brothers?
No.
Oh.
Yeah!
I was gonna say...
I was gonna...
Round 2 I guess.
Part of the dangler feeler used by the demon bale.
Bales?
Those who take it up will find a new source of power.
How do you say that?
Is that a V?
Rusalka corpse?
Witnessed.
All the robs.
So we closed this up.
Neat.
There's nothing else around here?
Alright, let's get out of here.
Let's get out of here.
Did something open up and I missed it?
Yes indeed.
Yippee!
S!
Stylish points!
Wow!
What time is it?
Oh, I guess I should call it here.
Um...
One hour until map shift.
Yeah!
I just noticed too.
One hour warning.
Dang!
I mean, I could maybe do one more.
But I do wanna eat too.
Okay.
Let's call it here.
A bit of a short...
Just a warm up of DMC4.
A little introduction.
Let's see.
How many missions did we get through?
Not very many.
I think like four?
Yeah, we're on five.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
How are you liking Nero?
I just...
I don't dislike him.
He's basically Dante Jr. But...
I do like the grabby grab.
I like that a lot actually.
I think that's a lot of fun.
And...
Wait, we're a fourth of the way through?
No way.
Hi from Taiwan.
Hello!
I hope you're having a good time too.
She's got that punk attitude.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's very unique gameplay.
There's a lot that...
You know, I see some people in the chat saying like...
Oh, I never really used the rev.
And things like that.
So...
I definitely will have to fall into my own sort of gameplay style.
But so far...
I mean...
After...
Three was so...
Three was so difficult.
And I have not unlocked easy mode!
Aren't you guys proud of me?
I didn't get the easy mode.
It's now unlocked.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, it was unlocked from the beginning.
It was the human mode, wasn't it?
Well...
Whatever!
I
didn't have to use it.
Definitely can see where they made improvements though.
From the...
From one and three.
Obviously three.
You can see that too.
But three is so tricky also.
I'm curious though.
With the boss that we just did.
I kind of want to see what new powers we have.
That was one of my favorite things about three.
Was being able to switch between all the different weapons.
I like...
I thought that was a lot of fun.
So...
Smosh has this character called the Chosen.
Basically a weeb that thinks he's better than everybody.
I always think of him when playing Vergil.
He hosted a Beyblade tournament.
Oh!
Who's Smosh?
Weapon switching essential to the series after three.
Wait, so do we also then get that too?
YouTube comedy channel.
Oh!
That!
I...
I never watched them.
It's a lot for you to discover about this game.
I could tell!
But that's always one of the fun things about these types of games.
I'm sorry to bring up Metal Gear again, but I will.
But everybody can play the game in the way that they wish to play the game.
So there's no right way.
Or I guess there is technically a wrong way.
But you know, same with Metal Gear.
You can be as stealthy or as crazy as you want.
And that's fun.
That's fun!
Love self-expression in games.
Yeah!
Metal Gear Revenge?
I do not feel that she is sorry.
I'm never sorry for bringing up Metal Gear.
It's all that I know.
I've only played one game.
Metal Gear.
The legendary Dark Knight mode is crazy because it summons three times the mobs.
I was just thinking honestly though that there doesn't seem to be so many mobs spawning.
I think three has really leveled me up as a gamer.
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I think so.
Wait, that did save, right?
Oh shoot.
I just realized.
That did save.
It said load.
OK, we're fine.
Tomorrow, Rafi!
No games, only Metal Gear.
I don't know.
I am streaming tomorrow.
Do you want me to sing tomorrow for you?
You don't have to remind me though.
I'll just sing today just in case.
We'll pretend it's tomorrow.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Rafi Raphael.
Happy birthday!
What console did this game come off...
Come...
Released on?
PS2 or PS3?
PS3.
360.
OK, that's what I thought.
360 PS3.
Are you enjoying Peak DMC?
I am.
Game is so much fun.
Look, there's the Devil May Cry right there.
Will we go there?
I want to go to there.
I finished my first MGS game, Snake Eater.
I hope you liked it.
This is the first multi-platform DMC.
I like how both of you said that at the same time.
3DS.
Oh my gosh, imagine Devil May Cry on the 3DS.
Imagine.
My game just crashed.
Well, I think...
I think my computer is kicking me out.
I didn't do anything.
Why did my game just crash?
OK, well...
That was silly.
Oh, and we got to beat the first boss.
So that's fun too.
I think this is a good stopping point, honestly.
Tsumito!
If you are a member...
If you are a part of membership...
In 50 minutes, we'll be doing a stream.
And if you're watching the VOD...
Thank you for watching the VOD.
And thanks for watching all the way until now.
And...
If you are a VOD member, you can watch that.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
You guys have gone insane.
Are you crazy?
Paperbacks, thank you for the 5 gifted.
Jared, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I hope you guys had a good weekend.
And we'll finish off the weekend together.
If you want.
It's not like I want you there or anything.
It's not like you have, you know...
It's not like...
OK, anyway, bye!
If you, you know, would be kind of cool.
You know.
I
don't know.
I'm just saying.
Just...